can we actually create intelligence
questions that said can they actually
control our life questions that said
would they be able to become creative
humanity is the only species capable of
innovation or creativity or art or music
and we've been proven wrong on every
single one of those so far they've
created better music than us they write
better than us they create better art
than us and yes absolutely we have forms
of intelligence that surpass human
intelligence in many ways and they're
controlling us in so many ways when you
think about every piece of content
that's ever been recommended to you from
an AI today on social media